four three two
you're listening to the hp podcast
welcome everybody
[Music]
they said we would never make it to
number five but you know we like to find
the odds
we're all about that i'm wearing james
charles new merch
my sister nice you guys like it
actually no this is a new teddy fresh
hoodie that's out now
so is that shirt teddy friends.com um
jay-z wrote our intro so shout out to
jay-z
you know i called up jay-z one day and i
was like hey jizzy
did i call him jizzy no i don't think so
this doesn't change i think he has like
a million nicknames but not jesus
no that sounds like geez like it's my
boy jizzy
i'm gonna take a jizzy i said hey boy i
said aj can you hit me with one of your
jizzies
and he's like i got you is it can i get
it to
two weeks i was like bro how about two
days i mean come on you owe me
so he hooked this up get out anyway look
as you guys may know we are embroidered
in a little tiny bit of a controversy
with james charles
the fat and by the way it's not because
he's got a bigger fatter ass than me
because he doesn't not that you say that
that's a whole different issue
people be like ethan you're just mad
because he has a fatter ass than you
i actually have not seen my sister is
that
but now i doubt everything yeah
there's definitely an ulterior motive by
the way you can compare ass to ass and
decide for yourself it was a feather ass
and and i do want to preface this by
saying
that i have nothing personal about james
charles and
my intention with this of calling him
out
was not i don't i really really wanted
to avoid
drama and that's why i d i private
messaged him before going public
with this but like the thing is i mean
you guys know because you guys are fans
but a lot of people don't understand
is that that hoodie is like our most
iconic piece and
it's our number one seller it has been
for years and like james
charles making it's it's exactly the
same hoodie
it's actually been ripped off a lot too
but
normally like here let me show it
because people may not know we wouldn't
really
um do anything about it because what can
you do
but i think in this case it just kind of
hurt because it's a fellow youtuber
who's actually got way bigger influence
than we are
way big and so it just kind of hurts but
you know well the thing is like things
do happen there's tons of websites
like zazzle and exactly exactly faithful
website a complete exact copy of it
people all over the internet have been
doing that yeah
and then but like the thing is that
well here i tweeted out i didn't know i
we didn't invent color blocking which is
again something that i really stand
behind because a lot color blocking is
very popular and a lot of people do
color blocks and i would never dream of
saying
you know oh you you own color block we
own color blocking and you're stealing
so
but the thing is here is that i'm having
a hard time with his merch
because this is the exact same design as
ela's
combined with the fact that his audience
is so huge they're going to start
accusing us of plagiarism
what do you think so here's his hoodie
and then here's our hoodie
it's the same sleeve color teal and
purple
the same body color it's just a little
lighter really
same hood even the hood and the
drawstring are yellow the sleeves are
yellow
i i mean it's it's
it's it's literally exactly the same
and so and then here's the thing that
blew my mind is like on vine because now
i'm like a vine
i'm the up and coming vine superstar
it's called tick
100 000 followers in like one week
your sensation i am a sensation thank
you for finally saying
you have a really like natural talent at
it
it's like you were meant for it it's a
shame that i got started so late
yeah and now the news just came through
that this sunday they're going to stop
downloads and updates which i'm so i'm
so gutted now
tick tock is my home i actually see it
and
like i'm really dry this morning
i really i don't know what to do like on
a real level
because like two weeks ago like no need
to ban tick-tock
right loud then sorry i think that um
two weeks ago i was like [ __ ] tick-tock
they're a threat to our national
security shut it down
and now i'm like tick-tock is our home
not kidding i hope is my home
i hope that they can work it out though
i really hope that anyway look at the
views on
on james charles tick tock he's like
mega famous and he's friends with all
these crazy ass superstars there
he even had this girl uh what's her name
charlie or
what who's emilio yeah dude by the way i
i saw a stat
she got 7 billion views last month on
tick tock
whoa in a month yes in a month
what yes wow so here here's
all the tick tocks where he was
promoting the hoodie it has a combined
view count of like 60 mil yeah
60 million maybe more i mean maybe more
so i really think it looks like your
hoodie you think it looks like my hoodie
no i don't think it looks like your
hoodie at all
what why are you saying that because
it's it's more uh
it's more pasteli than uh than yours are
you making a joke i'm
i'm [ __ ] you dan i'm repeating what i
saw in a lot of comments of people that
were
not saying it's more well the people i
saw who are in denial about it are i
think they didn't look too close because
what they were saying was like oh peop
like they're like the simon has a color
block hoodie you're gonna call them out
and i'm like no
it's different colors it's completely
different this
is the same exact colors in the same
exact spot
i mean the yellow trim the yellow draw
cords it's literally
a carbon copy i know i couldn't believe
i was being sarcastic i couldn't believe
some of the
the denialism that i was seeing anyway
situation but hold on
yeah what does aien think about uh about
it
did james charles steal our design ai-n
what is happening hello i can't see i
don't know what happened with this call
how do i pull well i don't i don't think
they look similar at all
i i'm really actually i've already
pre-ordered a handful of them i think
they're going to really
why do you need so many well you know
there's seven days in the week ethan
right do you even have arms or like a
whole torso
oh what now your anti-arm
is that our color block hoodie in the
garbage
car just doing a little spring cleaning
i don't know what you're talking about
this whole thing this guy i mean i
brought you
into this world and you're gonna come
here and and
support james charles ripping our hoodie
off i mean this is outrageous
wait this is a hoodie oh i've been using
it as a dish rag
oh no wow well thanks for the
thanks for the 85 bucks
you just listen to that that sounds like
a fever dream
all right let's get rid of him a b how
are you doing you're looking sharp
you're looking sharp man oh thank you
you like it she looks so good bro
thanks man thank you og piece right here
yeah 2017 all the way back
2017. anyway so like
i basically just out of pure sep
self uh preservation was like look i
gotta i
we thought about it for a few days
because people it started popping up
more and more people being like hey
james charles is ripping your [ __ ] off
read your [ __ ] off
and i thought about it for a long time
and i damned him in the dms and i i want
to share it so [ __ ] bad because he
brought it up when i
messaged him he's like here let me show
you
let me show you what he responded to me
he says when you dm to me yesterday i
sent you the original photo that
inspired my collection
explained i've never seen your brand but
also asked what you wanted me to do
you didn't reply after last year i vowed
to keep conversations private and create
solutions not drama
so when i dm'd him first of all he was
super
dismissive and flippant and rude because
my intention was to be like i don't want
it to come public and i want to talk to
him first and just see what he has to
say
and he was like he's like uh
i've never heard of your brand i don't
know anything about it and and uh
and i don't know what you're talking
about and i already made it there's
nothing i can do
and he was like super rude too he's like
why are you even messaging me he said
why are you even messaging me are you
just trying to start drama
but if that if i was trying to start
drama i would have just tweeted and not
messaged him
and then he goes like well we should
resolve this in the dms and then he says
i asked what you wanted to do and you
didn't respond which is not true
i said i mean he said he's going to sell
them anyway so what
what is there to do about it well but
but it's literally not true he said i'm
gonna talk to my design team and get
back to you and three days passed
and so i was like well he's just there's
just nothing's gonna happen
and i have to protect our our brand and
your your work because
again he he's gonna sell a billion of
these hoodies
and he's just gonna kill this style
which is our
frankly bread and butter i mean
i don't know if it's gonna kill the
style but um
it's fine i think that it was fine to
make it public just so
people are aware and that's it yeah just
leave it at that
because there but again his you saw the
60 million people are like
you know they don't know and i think
it's a little
if it was just a little tiny bit
different i wouldn't have said a [ __ ]
thing
yeah it's identical and that's the part
that kills me right
so anyway also he goes uh he also met
this is the part that i really want to
share but you won't let me
the thing is he brought up the dm so i
feel like he's saying it's okay to share
it
he's not but he said he literally
said after i confronted him and i hadn't
seen this colorway here
he says oof just to give you a heads up
it appears that this one has the exact
same colors
and it looks like the design team
totally ripped you off
he literally said my sisters and i said
wow so it doesn't seem like a
coincidence does it and he said
it's not he says it does not appear to
be in a coincidence so he literally
admit
that they ripped us off in the dm it
seems pretty clear that
um potentially he personally was not
aware
although that is very questionable too
but
let's say that it was not someone on his
team was but
it doesn't matter i mean ultimately it's
his responsibility
yeah that's the thing he keeps skirting
around it's like oh my designers did it
but like it's your company and i totally
believe that he wouldn't by the way
when i first saw that i figured like oh
there's no way he would
knowingly just rip us off it must have
been someone in his team and he wasn't
aware
but now he's trying to say like i've
never seen your brand i don't know
anything about teddy fresh i never heard
of teddy fresh
and then now a bunch of people are like
dude your best friend
is wearing teddy fresh and he also said
to you like
our audience is completely different too
so i wouldn't even worry oh yeah that's
like that's actually not true
well that was such a douchey comment he
goes well anyway he's aware of
the size or audience of teddy fresh and
it's actually just not true
it's a lot on tick tock and he is a lot
on tick tock so it is the same people
it is well yeah and that whole premise
is just so douchey and dismissive he
goes
yeah he goes well anyway even if i did
rip you off it's not even the same
audience so
it won't matter i was like okay i i i
wish i could share this conversation
with you guys well we just did
yeah i guess but people got to see to
believe man
the thing is he was he was just super
rude to me and i i was trying to be
really polite but
i don't know yeah and then the the irony
on top of it all
because james charles acts like this
whole thing is so crazy
but like this tweet from september 2019
really shows that he
knows what it's like there was a
there was another company that knocked
off his color palette
and so he tweeted this and he called
them out on instagram he said
there are so many colors you can put
into an eyeshadow palette and i'm not
claiming to
own specific colors but when you copy
the exact
shades and layout for my palette without
even trying to hide it clown emoji i
mean
that's he's describing exactly what
happened right
so he should have some empathy
for for where we're coming from instead
of being so flippant and dismissive
because he whether he knows it or not he
is that big company
right you know he's going to sell a
bajillion of that [ __ ]
so we have people in the chat right now
saying that they're fans of both h3 and
james charles just for the record
yeah i know a lot of people that are
because he has so many fans i mean his
audience he's way bigger than us
obviously there's an overlap right and
it's the same age
like i mean there's a range obviously
but there's a lot of the same people
this was this was it by the way and like
yeah i see the comparison but i wouldn't
even go as far to say that his hoodie is
way more of a direct ripoff than this
is you know and he had like this whole
thing he wrote up which i'm not going to
read but
you know he talks about how it's his
artistic integrity and he spent all this
time on the colors and then they're just
gonna rip him off and i'm like dude
i just don't know why you don't have
more empathy for us if you're willing to
say all that stuff in your own defense
you know and there's actually let me go
let me go over to uh have you guys heard
of ethan klein
h3 tick tock he's kind of a huge up and
comer
in 2020. let me show you
when you see it um next to each other
like this you can really see i mean it
looks like he's wearing my hoodie
and by the way theodore was so cute when
i was filming this i was filming this
and i didn't even know he was standing
there looking at the camera
and then when i look back at the video
he was with me right but i didn't know
he was staring
and then when i looked back it was so
cute and he was like
he saw himself in the tick tock and then
he smiled and looked away he got all
embarrassed
he's so [ __ ] awesome so cute oh my
god
he's the best ever
ethan collins another thing is people
are only focusing on the colors but the
placement
like i don't know any other hoodie that
has that placement of the colors in that
way
it's it's identical i mean it's the same
hoodie that's the thing if the even if
you use the same colors in a different
placement
let's say let's say that this sleeve was
the body and this was the sleeve i
wouldn't have said
all the factors together it's the fact
that we are from the same
environment we do business in the same
way we're on the same platforms
that that all is combined together to
just feel very
bad that's all right so that's that
and anyway i think for the most part
anyone
who isn't like a ride-or-die james
charles fan our keemstar totally
understands where we're coming from
you know what i mean like i i don't want
to com i don't want to
seem like a petty whiny [ __ ] but like
you know
it's exactly the same h3h3
is [ __ ] innocent he changed his tune
on us
beautiful nice he must be having an off
day yeah what happened to him
you got like a brain tumor or something
where it makes you nice
i'm not a democrat that makes sense
anyway let's get to the after dark shall
we
you guys remember that girl that spit on
her dog
uh right the poor girl yeah
the people who uploaded by accident the
video
i forgot that she was like the biggest
oopsie ever
self-owned ever brooke house i forget
her name
anyway yeah she accidentally uploaded a
video of her spitting and beating the
crap out of her dog
and then everyone was like and actually
what was especially ironic was that um
it's way too loud down i don't know if
you could if you adjusted that already
um
what was especially ironic is that her
whole channel is dedicated to her
loving relationship with her dogs and
then she
how do you even accidentally upload a
video and then of all the things i mean
you spitting on your dog well
so anyway she finally oh she disabled
like
ratio man and disabled comments man
not like this oh that's so sad yeah as
you can imagine it was absolutely brutal
it was like 99
down boat oh no yeah it was brutal one
year later it's already been one year
yeah wow it feels longer to me really
yeah doesn't to me seems like she just
spit and beat the crap out of her dog
yesterday
yeah anyway she she found this boyfriend
who's like a
crazy uh zealous religious
cultish christian and he like hijacked
her video and just started
ranting in it like it's not even her
it's so bizarre
it's the most bizarre [ __ ] i have a very
important video for you guys today
this is something that i've wanted to
film for basically the entire past year
of my life
and it's something that's been on my
mind countless times
i want to tell you guys exactly what
happened between me and my dog give you
a hundred percent
of the what happened between me
exactly as if it does i really want to
give you as much information so anyway
she just goes on this part isn't
interesting she just goes on to say
that she felt terrible and that she
still
she didn't spit on her dog but come on
we all know she's putting her dog
but anyway she wants us to know that
even if we continue to hate her she
loves
us yadda yadda and then
after 20 minutes
a [ __ ] total psycho appears
wait which is an hour and 20 minutes
so she talks for 20 minutes like a
normal youtube video
and then peyote
cult leader logan paul
[Laughter]
her boyfriend logan paul takes the
camera and starts ranting
you got to say his name what is his name
his name
is teal teal like the caller
except spelled with an e at the end huh
i've met someone named teal i don't
think that's crazy
what you know what nelly yeah i met i
know it i knew a teal i thought it was a
really pretty name
dan [ __ ] you then
that's not the worst name ever if his
name was like butt plug i'd be like yeah
that's crazy [ __ ] you dan
how's it going so here i want to see
when she passes it off tell you every
single one of you you are all
loved and i will see you guys very soon
with a brand new video she's like bye
23 minutes you know long but but normal
video
on youtube and then boyfriend picks up
the cam hey everyone how's it going hope
you're doing well
for those of you who don't know my name
is teal i am brooke's boyfriend
and i'm going to share with you guys an
hour my side my perspective
um of the situation that took place
between brook and her dog a little bit
over a year ago now
for those of you still watching thank
you for continuing to watch this whole
entire video we appreciate it i
appreciate it i know you guys are
already so let me get nobody
starts getting worked up more and more
as the video goes on so was he there
no no no he literally just squeezed his
way into her life trying to get exposure
it seems like
anyway here he starts to get worked up
is
understand me on this now so many people
seen this video millions of people seen
this video blow up guys
and and now after i asked brooke hey
have you done an apology video she said
yes but it wasn't one then i told her i
said bro listen here's what we're gonna
do
20 minutes bro i mean you told me if
you're on board i said brooke listen
i've i've i've been having these
messages i've been having these deep
talks for those of you who know me you
guys
i did the gratitude challenge i love
just getting in front of a camera or
just talking to friends family whatever
i love
having deep talks mainly always jesus
christ comes up and my relationship my
faith with him jesus christ
is solely where all of this other stuff
in my life comes from and that's the
only reason i have to bring him up in
everything he's already been talking for
20 minutes
after that bro i said bro here's what
we're going to do we're going to make an
apology video
but brooke i want to make videos too i'm
trying to make videos that speak to
people that reach people because i know
i have a perspective on life they can
reach so many people
i know what happened he was like this
video is going to get a lot of views
and so i'm going to hijack the [ __ ] out
of it
yeah anyway here he he continues to get
all worked up
his eyes get crazy and everything here
check this [ __ ] out speak but i can
or an hour in i can smell i can hear i
can look
i can see i can
it's the weirdest video ever and i
literally just told you guys
i had no say in this as a matter of fact
you didn't have a say in this this is
breathing on this very earth right now
the president
your favorite athlete your your your
favorite movie star whatever is he
saying anything
no remember how this started with her
talking about her dog yeah
so my friends i am simply making you
aware i am simply encouraging you
that's a good question he why is he in
such a remote location he
probably just buried a body then he
starts screaming
different stages of mania where is it
going to get any of us
what power do we have what judgment do
we have
what state do you have when we die we
take our last breath what
day do you have about what brooke's
house did to result
you'll tell me why
they're not physically together so many
people she was in a different car
yeah no and not in the desert i can tell
he hijacked her
her editing look at the world right now
look at america right now look at the
evil look at the hate
look at the sadness crazy right this is
an audition for something
yeah i mean this is his big break oh
then they
end by i don't know how much of this i
want to watch but
it's [ __ ] crazy i mean are you
interested in this hello kind of okay
good
this is the weirdest video i've ever
seen not acknowledge the things that i
said
you can't acknowledge that you can't you
can't fight again there there's no
way you can say against that all of this
stuff i'm amazing
i'm not actually true people are saying
cocaine that actually
that actually sounds right i'll continue
to be so passionate it's not about what
you guys think about me
it's not about the comments you write
about me it's not about the comments you
write about brooke the comments around
her youtube her facebook her instagram
it's not about
an hour 15 bro matter of fact if that's
what it takes for something
if as if this story couldn't get weirder
you know
and then and finally after explaining
why she spit and beat the crap out of
her dog
they plugged their couple's channel oh
updating you guys two weeks ago stepping
up
wow and this guy's a little spooky i
already got mine in okay not quite as
much
so how's the chat okay anything to
report
um they're big fans of teal
of the name teal or the guy yeah you
guys just want to watch teal all day
get inspired learn about faith in god
when are you having your mom's house
back on oh we have them on the calendar
my birthday today 28 years young
28 god bless you dude congratulations
brandon
i'm donating just to say i love to
refresh
we love you too joey salads keep sending
me these text messages
we got more people just standing up for
teddy fresh you guys
are they're doing what for teddy fresh
they're just sending a lot of free time
oh thank you guys thank you so much
man we love you guys we know you guys
understand you guys are the best
oh so joey salads he's always sends me
these text messages
little life updates and so he was
spreading misinformation
him covered misinformation on
which is the worst [ __ ] ever right but
this is really interesting he goes
so he was spreading misinformation
on the joey salad show the joey saladino
show
and so what they did is they banned all
of his channels
because he set up like this right-wing
and what on what
platform i think it was on you yeah it
was on youtube
and so he set up this joey saladino show
which is like some right wing podcast
and of course joey is spreading covet 19
misinformation
so they go you just pee on yourself
that's the new vaccine you're right yes
pee in your mouth bro there's a lot of
people that believe you're
curious [ __ ] but anyway they say given
the severity of the violation
we have suspended monetization for all
of your channels
the joey saladino show joey salads and
the salad family
the salad family yeah what is the salad
family
what has been it's like so funny
and i said joey so what is what was his
og
channel joey salads so that's awesome
yeah they got him good
i said joey maybe you shouldn't be
spreading kova 19 misinformation
he didn't even deny it he just goes he
goes yeah i've been
i've been cleaning up my [ __ ] recently
but all week i've been getting flagged
on videos at four to six months old
that's so joey like he's like yeah not
even are you
i know it's the best game views that's
why you gotta love joey because when we
because when we were like yo you fake
the trump
first it's like you're ruining society
and he says
yeah yeah yeah i'll change it i'll make
a new video
yeah but you that's why you to love joey
because
no other prankster would come before you
to lay themselves on the altar yeah and
just sacrifice their body
like like he does you know what i mean
he's like yeah i was spreading coveted
misinformation
i was trying to clean up my act but uh
they still got me
it's awesome cool nice update
do we have men of culture in the chat do
we have any men of culture in the chat
oh do we meet again men of culture
will you come out with new colorways of
the sandals i think
we will but it won't be until next
summer next year
okay let me show you this new channel we
found this is for men of culture only
because i thought it was so funny the
not safe for work uh
or safe for work really like porn i
guess you could call it
wait someone said random guy at work
kissed me during coving would love to
talk about it with you guys
call in get that person on the phone
right now zach a random guy kissed you
that's a crime what the [ __ ] is that
that sounds horrible i would be so
scared
anyway ela i'm trying to talk to the men
of culture
are you a man of culture so before you
start that let me also answer one more
question oh go ahead
oh are you all excited to host trisha
for rosh hashanah
as soon as we finish this the family is
coming over
am i excited including trish i mean it's
gonna be
interesting i didn't really know how
she's gonna meld with the
with the family i'm curious everyone is
not everyone is curious in the family
too
why did you just type ass pizza elo oh
just type googled ass pizza because
that's the hat that i'm wearing people
were wondering what am i wearing oh i
wanted that's the name of the brand
pizza yeah it's this guy on instagram
uh check him out it's cool yeah that hat
is sick by the way
yeah why did i bet you that so
i don't know because trisha demands so
much attention she's so much the center
of attention that i wonder how she'll
i am a little nervous about that like
so i'm wondering if she's capable of
just being a polite house guest
i guess we'll find out we'll find out
yeah i mean we we are all very casual
and it's
usually very like not too fancy too and
i feel like she's gonna come all blinged
out i'm in her pink rolls roy
you think she's gonna have a camera yeah
i don't think
oh she can't be taking photos i don't
care i gotta tell her she can't be
social meeting
no tick tocks no snaps log at the client
house she's gonna ask to do tick tocks
with me
no she's not we're not doing tick-tock
we're just supposed to be real
no this is not about tick-tock
as much as i am a rising star
well you guys update about what happens
i'm sure we will yeah yeah on monday
when they record another episode and she
tries to [ __ ] my dad
anyway man of culture i really like
these i think i find these all so funny
the uh safe for work like nonchalant
kind of porn
sites on on youtube and there's so many
of them
it's fun to just work through them this
is a new one i don't know it's like from
three weeks ago already they have their
most viewed video 2.3 million
look at the thumbnail look at that
[ __ ] thumbnail dude
it's just yoga what what look at all
these thumbnails brats
i hate that position which one this one
or like that just doesn't even look that
good to me
what for jerking off or for yoga it's
just not that flattering
no it's not it's really not flattering
but like
i wouldn't want to get a picture of
myself like that you know certainly gets
your attention doesn't it
well let's see and let me remind you
guys uh
my men of culture we are watching this
video for yoga tips
all right like i don't know what y'all
are gonna be thinking about but this is
about the yoga
okay and it always has been and always
will be
let me mute it i don't think there's
it's just some kind of sexy music
yeah so clearly you know you just
spread your legs and doing she's doing
like crunches or something and then
her feet obviously are you got to see
what her feet are doing
so shameless
and uh really just you yeah you're just
gonna do be doing this with your knees
oh my gosh stretching and lifting it's
that's ridiculous it's a really good
workout
fantastic workout you can see
zach are you a fan of this yoga it's all
over my [ __ ]
youtube recommendation why because you
did that you put this together
uh you could say that sure oh were you
watching this you were just watching it
or did you
who put this together i well
someone found the channel but i put
together i found the channel and i
shipped it to zach okay good area
exactly did you beat off while doing
research for this or
or any yoga i don't think i can comment
on that later oh my god you beat off to
this bro
yeah you know zach did
you know zach did no no comment
no comment from zach what a legend well
you said you couldn't beat off to the
other one so this one you enjoyed better
i i think so
i mean i definitely have the the workout
fetish so
uh oh you got all the fetishes yeah
there's a bunch of them but this is just
i don't see what's the problem i mean
if you go on youtube or peloton or
whatever i mean
she's just giving lessons you i don't
know why you have to make everything
sexual
yeah i mean something must be wrong with
my head right they've got a meter too so
you know when the bus
normal usually it's to tell you when to
exercise
over this tells you when to bust or not
yeah something wrong with you
something's sick in the head bro yeah
anyway three weeks ago 2.2 million views
wow
it's so good this one let's see this one
is from this year
yeah who are you to judge how they
convey their art
she's lifting she's thrusting wait she's
not even doing anything
well oh is she speaking like
japanese yeah those guys know how to do
it over in japan they know how to i
don't know if it's
probably japanese but it could be
something else
what do i know but they really know how
to do it over there
yoga yeah
everyone at home is like i can't watch
this wherever i am i can't watch this
and this one is just super useful
because
it just really instructs how to open
your thighs and
you know close them sure you can
open your eyes definitely zach can you
tell me which video you bust to
uh again i feel like this is more of a
starter
um oh just got you got you down yeah all
right
right that's what you said well which is
the one can you tell me that
that you found the most instructive tier
yoga
it was the the top one the tab
training for beautiful legs
oh this one yeah wait which one
oh they all say yeah they all say that
the the 2.1 million views one
i just highlighted it 2.1 oh it's the
one we watched the most popular one
exactly oh yeah you found that most
instructive
it was quite ironic this one's only
three no i didn't say erotic i said it's
destructive
this one's from three days ago it's
blowing up 360 000.
it was uh it's so good it's
so good see this one's actually just
pretty pretty normal anyway there's just
one channel like there's a bunch of them
that one is japanese yoga channel called
do it together don't stop that's what it
translates to
oh this one was really funny i was doing
research
last night and there's just this one
shot i think it's japanese
looking at those letters didn't i say
japanese you said
it says japanese in the dark but i don't
think that's right that looks like
chinese to me
guys i have some breaking news go ahead
um kim kardashian
just posted james charles merch what
oh my god where what what
i'll i'll send it in what see this is
the problem
this is exactly why this is important
because
he's going so kim kardashian just posted
james charles merch
did he pay her to do this why would she
do that
see hold up let's see yeah let me see
ian send me the image i'm actually my
heart is pounding because i
i'm so upset about this
that's [ __ ]
good job on the breaking report by the
way
yeah sorry i didn't know if i should
interrupt no yeah you definitely did the
right thing
it's an instagram story she said uh
she said james charles sent the most
beautiful flowers with some sister merch
oh she liked the flowers more than the
mer
hey that's a nice color palette
the flowers yeah yeah it is pretty dope
looks familiar
you know this is exactly the problem
right
because this is going main and this is
what people [ __ ] about like zara and
all this [ __ ] you know
it's so easy for people to [ __ ] about
how these companies steal designs but
now all of a sudden
it's happening right here
by a fellow creator and it's not
again it's not even a little different
that's the issue i have to i have to say
that because i don't want people to
think i'm just bitching about
he did a color block it's exactly the
same
it's exactly the same
you know what he said in the dm when i
was like it's exactly the same he goes
no the pocket's yellow
i was like oh okay genius
he just wrote sisters across the chest
that's crazy dude
so all i gotta do is send her flowers
and she'll post no [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i gotta do to get in her
stories
i mean how many views does this story go
like a bit just gazillion
probably like 20 million or something i
mean you know well she has 188 million
followers
yeah yeah doesn't kylie have more though
it's bigger than any advertisement you
could do um
but she does have like 30 stories posted
just from the past
24 hours but yeah yeah the thing is um
i've noticed 98 million followers i've
noticed when i post more stories
then they get more views like
individually and not the opposite
which is interesting when i post one
story it gets less views
then if i post like five in a day they
get way more views each one
if you if you look at the photo on top
all those little lines that's how many
stories she has yeah no i see that
but i think yeah
yeah that's wild but i think people are
tuning in oh yeah definitely
um he's trying to just
i think he's just trying to pretend like
nothing's going on so i don't know
but ultimately i mean look he keep what
can he do what can we do
i don't know i just want people to know
that
this is [ __ ] same honey you know
anyway we were [ __ ] exercising so
let's stay focused shall we there are
some straight up weirdos
on the internet does aan also sleepwalk
ai in do you sleepwalk
no i'm always awake always watching all
right that's
that's that's what i expected
what if there's nothing to watch what if
everyone else is sleeping
i see your lips flapping i stumped you i
stumped you
anyway here i wanted to show you guys
this one scene before i moved on
and maybe you can explain to me what the
[ __ ] is going on because i couldn't
figure it out
why is there a woman sleeping in the
background
punched over oh my god
why why is this happening
that turns me weird why is she there
slumped over
maybe it's a kink what could possibly be
the explanation here she is look at this
zach does this part of the fetish
can you explain does this do anything
for you zach no the sleeping thing
doesn't but there is a there is
a sleeping fetish out there um
but which like like a sleeping beauty
type thing you know
but she's just like slumped over in the
background
oh and now she's gone oh my god i feel
like that was a mistake
but why was she there oh yeah yeah that
that kind of creeped me out oh she's
back you know
she's back here now oh she's just
sitting there
no she's wait what what is going on
she's kind of like dozed off but
this gives me human trafficking vibes if
i can just
say that you know what i mean like
what in the [ __ ] bro
that turns me on i feel like she thought
she was probably not going to be
included in the shot
but they lined her up perfectly how
could they not
look look at this shot
looks like she's dozed off yeah this is
pretty bizarre maybe she just had a good
workout
she's human trafficked well that's just
the only explanation
that's [ __ ] up man you guys want to
take a call
yeah we have that uh person that got
kissed during covid
oh okay okay i'm bringing her on right
now
talk to me baby
okay they're on the line hello
who do we have on the line here
all right nice to see you
you guys want to watch another uh hello
oh i wanted to show you speaking of like
the safe for work
porn thing you know tick tock is super
uh safe for work like they don't
tolerate any shenanigans
so the fact that this channel exists is
just awesome she literally just does
cooking videos
and see-through top with no bra
do you want to start cutting board with
flour zach could you do you want to drop
your pizza
for you use your fingers
it's just it's all of our videos are the
same two of my favorite things food and
boobs
you want to do is take some cauliflower
and cut into she's kind of a genius
though right
and then you want to transfer mixing
bowl drizzle um
i mean it works today i'm going to show
you she's got like an only fans too
oh she does yeah you see that crosstalk
she's [ __ ] epic look at this [ __ ]
it's like who [ __ ] cares she's
cracking an egg you know what i mean
you literally stay for the titties
it's great it's a whole channel man
thoughts does the recipes even make
sense so it's just like
who know nobody watches the recipe
you know what i mean like what is she
doing cucumber and bacon that doesn't
work
i know cucumber and bacon doesn't work
was she making some broke-ass cobb
don't you need other ingredients okay
let's see where this goes
okay so she has some lettuce actually i
mean do i really need like is this
really helpful i know what a cobb salad
yes
all she did was cut bacon and egg
this was helpful for you zach yeah i
mean she was making it crafting a
fantastic meal
yeah yeah i believe they call it culture
food yeah
okay let's see what else we got how to
make
this is called how to make a hard-boiled
egg
i'm never gonna make you guys feel
stupid like as men
i never learned how to make it
uh does it make me feel stupid hmm
let me think about that i can't really
get i'll get back to you
[Laughter]
she literally made a video how to
hard-boil an egg this is genius ela
she could but like it's so stupid
i've never seen a dumber video how to
hard-boil an egg
add water so let's cover this add water
yeah
boil uh-huh cover
cook you really need the time wait what
the f oh she wait
wait did she turn on the microwave for
12 minutes
for a timer okay like really another
timer
put it in cold water crack and then peel
cut very informative
that's such a try hard way to boil an
egg by the way
yeah yeah you totally don't have to
cover it or put it in ice or
roll it on paper towel i think she's
just trying to
spice it up man i gotta see what other
how to make bacon jalapeno hoppers this
one you can actually see her boob
so it's pretty epic you know what i mean
you can't well exactly do you prefer
this one because you can't see the nip
but you can't see the under boob
i think i mean the under boob is nice i
mean
do you prefer the under boob or the nip
i think i gotta go nip on this one
really definitely well i thought it
would be the other way
this is so dumb and it's awesome
we need to watch trisha's insta story
really
am i i'm scared
best way to invent it definitely better
yeah at first good call
um here she's beating an egg yola
just whip it by the way who has this
thing
enjoy egg that's the video she used some
super obscure thing that nobody has
i wonder if she can show us how to drink
water and like how to
um open the fray how to make ice
how to make eyes i have no idea how you
did that
um how to melt how to melt cheese no
cheese would be nice you've probably
done that actually
how to make cheesy cauliflower thoughts
how
to fry she's a guy whoa whoa whoa whoa
how to fry bacon
slow down yeah whoa
getting super advanced how to make
guacamole
yeah she's a talent how to crack an egg
hmm
yeah um trisha is just prepping for the
holiday
and she starts the video saying it's a
great time to be a jew
um because she's so weird what is that
what do you think you're so weird about
it
oh she i saw one story where she goes
i'm eating jew food
i was like you know that sounds sounds
awful or anti-semitic to say jew food
i wanted to ask her about that on monday
i gotta talk to her about all this geo
obsession she's gotta know if it's worth
a watch but at the end there is
copyright music in the very last one
so okay well whatever just put it all
together about it on monday
yeah but can you there i forget where i
saw it but somebody showed it maybe it's
on the subreddit they says
she said i'm eating jew food and i
really wanted to just tell her you can't
say it like that
so somebody
what's that zach she put it on her tik
tok the jewel food thing
yeah she was eating this whole falafel
thing and wearing a shirt that says
israel
and uh she's learning here we're pretty
fast ethan by the way
no it's all [ __ ] she's she's don't
aren't you afraid my fear is in all this
is that
she's just she's really just like
she's not serious about your brother
it's just some phase where she's gonna
[ __ ] ruin his life and then move on
like he's just a fun novelty i mean yeah
i feel like
that was our obvious fear but now he's
somehow all into it and he's like like
how why is it that everything you're
doing is jewish now dude
it's just bizarre
fish what is she doing with the fish you
must be that girl that tries to be a
part of every culture that's not yours
oh she's making fun of herself
i'm confused stop what is she
doing i thought you were on a diet girl
oh it's a bamba
best haul of bread what is she she's so
you're leaning into this so
hard what the what's with the fish
for russia
head of the fish we don't do that in
america oh really
we don't do the head of the fish
business for rosh hashanah
happy rosh hashanah it's a great time to
be a jew because we're no longer in 2020
and it's new year
apple and honey is awesome what is a
great time to be a jew
sweet sweet member and a sweet sweet ass
gosh she is so [ __ ] twisted
what is she thinking when she does this
stuff yeah put this all to raiding my
jew lunch this was it
this was it yeah can you put all this
together for me like zachary
or something right
hey um this is a tangent but i have
something pretty spicy i'm going to send
you a
discord right now i love saying oh oh
cause then theodore does it take a look
at that
all right dan just sent me something our
boy mega awesome nerd just something
i've been in the hills [ __ ]
superstars feeling like a pop star
no no no who was playing that
it's from the video no it wasn't coming
from it's from research
it's what it was i think that was zach
what zach i didn't click on it dude
no it's the tick tock i just tested it
again yeah bruh
you know it's coming through the wrong
channel for some reason
anyways i'm opening it again so
because it keeps not opening the [ __ ]
tweet so i really don't even know how to
open the one
you just sent me it's i i try you guys
i'm trying
so hard i don't understand why it's not
it just keeps going to it okay here it
is i figured it out what the [ __ ]
okay so here we have he says he never
heard her
so here's him in a tick tock with
somebody wearing teddy fresh
yeah because he keeps saying i've never
heard of your brand i've never been on
youtube that's what i'm saying is huge
on tick tock and teddy fresh is huge on
tick tock it's like
there's like millions of of um
what do you call them tick tocks tick
tock with teddy fresh
tick tuckers and by the way that sure
looks great on him
yeah right it's awesome that he's
rocking it but yeah i mean
yeah he tried to like small-time me like
i don't know anything about your stupid
little brand
i've never heard of it i've never been
on your website
so hi sisters that guy looks pimp as a
[ __ ] though
best dress out of the group there i
think easy hands down and i'm not saying
that i mean
i'm not just saying that right right
all right the kid's gonna be exiled from
the group now
is the smoking james no they weren't
wearing teddy freddy no you mean james
can you put all this together uh zach or
ian the whole trisha thing i gotta ask
her about it on monday sure yeah
absolutely all right let me watch
this video can you bring this audio back
yeah thank you
and so so yummy 10 out of 10. um this
was aloe vera drink and i did not like
the little skin
chunks in there so i gave it a 2 out of
10. skin chunks
but no um the next thing i tried was
this i can't do this
that looks like persian food by the way
or indian food what she was just eating
no
it's middle eastern i got that uh covet
kiss call set up she had the wrong
input on her discord if you want to talk
to her
yeah i'm over it okay thank you though
who i would like to talk to is alyssa
who worked at the zoo
when harambe was shot
that was a big day for us uh people of
culture
right are you suggesting you masturbated
to that no oh because that's what that
means
gross bring in alyssa would you uh yes
i'm saying culturally a big day yeah it
was a big day
um so we watched the men of culture
videos
we've got a whole section here called
struggle and cringe
uh there's some great ones here man
but i don't know here let me do this and
then we'll bring her in because i don't
want to interrupt
or is she almost ready zach she she's
ready i can bring her you want to read
some donations and say what up to the
let's see what we got
um so dude
there's no way james people didn't tell
him about the f
does he think we're dumb probably
i mean enough of him watching yoga
videos i mean enough of his fans are
defending him
by saying they just say you know we
didn't invent
color blocking they just kind of reduce
it to that
cancel kim simp 30 fresh
good luck canceling that guy cancel ken
thank you so much for the gracious
donations and all the members by the way
i just want to say
i didn't say it our members you guys
thank you so much for the support it
means the world and it helps so much you
guys
can see we've been working really hard
on the podcast
and trying to make this a really fun
creative difference
place i really like the stuff we've been
doing the content court was so much fun
i want to keep that series going because
it really challenges the idea of what a
podcast can be and i love that
you know i think that's what it's all
about
you know i'm an artist as well and
always wanted to know more about your
personal art
more outside and separate from h3 and
teddy fresh love you guys
um honestly i'm so consumed with both
teddy fresh and the podcast that most of
my art
is that like every time i draw is
basically i sit down to draw stuff for
30 fresh so
that's mostly it but i i actually just
recently
been feeling like i want to stop
painting again
so i'm trying to
warm up into painting i'm trying to like
experiment a little bit with
what paints i like because i'm not sure
i'm such a marker
i don't think you need to worry about
painting you should just
the thing that i love about painting
though is that it's
they're so much better to present like
you can hang it in the house and it
looks
great i mean they have like body it's
like
beefy i mean and then like a beefy
marker work
yeah but those really work in small
sizes i mean you could make it big but
it would be so tedious to like cover
a large surface and i don't really like
tedious stuff
i'm not really about the repetitiveness
um but so i don't know i'll try it it's
paint has always been really challenging
for me yeah it seems really hard
um you want to talk to harambe yeah
let's bring in uh what's her name
alyssa israel alyssa
alyssa she's on right now alyssa
hello hello lissa
before we get started alyssa are you
team
james charles what do you think about
the whole uh color block thing
hello uh if you can't hear me i cannot
hear anyone
rest in peace harambe man this is how he
felt
nobody could hear him silently just
dying why
why has this happened hello is anybody
working on this
i don't see her what does it mean then i
mean
we test the discord it should be working
it's probably on it all right so okay
the second call of the day
thank you for calling
um zach did you when you bring them in
did you
do you talk to them i did yeah i just
talked to her on my end and it sounded
fine
there's a really sad story here
someone's best
friend um passed away in july
and the this past year um but they said
you guys helped me be able to continue
to laugh and
laugh and and enjoy life sorry i don't
know why it's so hard for me to read
well you know
the loss of a loved one is always tragic
but
like harambe we we i'm just saying
harambe was beloved by
all right dan is now in my computer what
is happening
i'm trying to see what's going on that's
pretty epic right
and then not even a heads up you just
sit here tinkering with them
giving condolences to somebody who just
has something well yeah didn't want to
interrupt yeah
that sounds really difficult especially
a best friend someone who's your age i
feel like
that's really hard it's hard to accept
death especially the death of a young i
mean
yeah like a young person it really hurts
i'm sorry about that it's a tragic
there's there's really nothing that hits
me harder than like
a really young person dying too young is
is always just [ __ ] you up you know
did you guys hear about the new sister
march
um no what is that i'm trying to open it
but dan is literally fighting for my
mouth
sam asked can we do a segment focusing
on eli and daniel what's that
sister merch of teddy fresh
no good um i liked it we we plan on
moving to our new office
maybe early next year because also
because like coveted obviously and
everything that's going on but i feel
like
once we're in the new place maybe it
will allow us to do that
and show more um i'm not even sure
really why i just think that
it's gonna work better there our current
office is so small
and it's a mess and there's not much to
show really
you want to watch some dude uh on his
first day get
his whole life [ __ ] up yes all right
so here's a dude now my internet is so
slow i can't even load this link
dan what have you done
dan what do you want me to say what have
you done
[Laughter]
why are you so why do you get so upset
i'm just goofing around i want to talk
about feet
is it working sister merch is tearing us
apart
yeah dan i i just i'm just trying i i
just want to know why you broke my
internet you got to say it's a prank
then it's just a it's just a um
it's just a gender reveal
there we go i'm just kidding then i
don't think you broke my
my internet i was trying to make a light
situation
out of it i know i'm saying the sign is
sick
homie's in here doing his first day of
work at the car wash
and he's using a power washer and then
it gets
tangled up and man that's a hell of a
birthday
i like how he doesn't even try to fight
it he's just rag the hauling
how did this happen i don't know i'll
let it play again
oh no this is a viral hog video
those guys are merciless [ __ ] viral hog
for the record
so he's just oh he's good
i'm surprised that doesn't happen more
like i guess you just kind of whoa
he doesn't find it at all man he's just
like let's go
his shoe came off yeah his shoe came off
whoa
that's awesome is the sprayer still
going and [ __ ] he's just cleaning
i mean i guess it's kind of fun i don't
think he had fun but
it's great happy birthday bill well
which is better so
do you think this one is better
but there's also another one
you like that sound ela
it's the guy blasting his face with
mentos you want to hear it again
wait that's not the sonic guy no this is
okay and then got it this one doesn't
have sound unfortunately
oh it does have sound oh my god watch it
again
i didn't know that sound
oh it's not really sound
why doesn't he try to fight it he
doesn't even grasp at the cable isn't
that
doesn't that surprise you he doesn't
even try to grab the cable man he's just
in for the ride
surprises me um
tell me what do you think this guy was
thinking either
what was he planning this tree to do
whoa cutting actually in his front yard
[Applause]
so do you think that was his house or
maybe even someone else's house
what would be worse your house or
someone else's house
you know what i mean i feel like
somebody else's house would be worth
but though those kind of yells
sound like personal like yeah his house
yeah yeah i get the feeling
i'm just asking which would you rather
drop the house off
yeah i guess like doing it to someone
else would be way worse
anyway this they did this really wrong
i've seen people cutting trees in our
yard you're supposed to cut it layer by
layer
i mean where was he expecting it to fall
in the middle of the street you know
what i mean
yeah this car is driving by this guy's
running for his life
wait let's there's a lot going on let's
try to dissect this
there's a car coming now there so like
if it fell that away there's a dude with
the rope running for his life look at
this
oh he's trying to get us to pull the
other way but yeah good luck
man have you ever [ __ ] up that bad in
your life
i don't think so i'm surprised how
strong the roof is on these houses to be
honest
yeah great any comments any anecdotes
i love it i love it
this was funny i love this either maybe
you can relate we just got a covet test
the other day
and so my heart goes out to this lady
they really got her good because when i
do the covet test here
all they do is swab the inside of my
nose a little bit it's not that crazy
they weren't a little dip this time for
me
really but it's so fast it's fine but
you see here
they really stay in there and they go
deep as hell
oh no so watch this and the ladies
already
okay
see i've not
put it in the mouth yeah all the way
back
get it yeah i have to do the other side
as well the other side
oh y'all
[Laughter]
yeah this is some serious [ __ ] since
y'all went down there where's this
oh god i'm disappointed i don't like go
ahead and get it that never happened to
us
watch this part it's so brutal
that's nothing like it no we've already
had it done like how many times
a five it was never like this the first
time we did it was really uncomfortable
they went really deep back but i never
had the throw
and the nostros
you know not cool not cool i don't want
to make people think that's what it's
like it's not
dude when we did it like two days ago or
yesterday i don't remember
they literally just did this in my nose
with the swab
was that gross now i've a little bit
unnecessary
any updates on james charles did uh
donald trump or
somebody tweet out his merch did i miss
not yet i love it i love it it possibly
uh
there's really no one bigger than kim
kardashian i mean he's kind of trying to
think of somebody
maybe kanye will pee on it well kanye
pee on sister merch good point
that's an endorsement i can get behind
you know last week we watched a kid [ __ ]
in the middle of a mall and someone
stepped in it and i thought that was
incredible
i thought i'd never see a video
like this again could you guys tell us
farting i kept leaning over
and i was like they probably know i'm
farting because i've leaned over a lot
when just now uh it wasn't loud but you
could smell it now if you
but having some gnarly gas bro like you
could tell them about it
yeah it's awful i'm considering like
when it happens i'm considering
getting up and walking into a different
room i don't i don't always have this
gas
right but every once in a while why is
that
i have no idea every once in a while it
just comes so
strong it's really bad like i have no
problem with
regular levels but this is like
well the problem is i start to feel bad
because i know it's so bad i mean i can
handle it
i kind of like when it's like worse than
ever because it's interesting
but i totally understand why you
wouldn't want to smell that i mean i
wouldn't want to smell anyone else's
fart that was that
dank so do you like to smell your own
farts
say again do you like the smell of your
own farts yeah for sure
well i wouldn't say i like it but it's
like it's okay
you know interesting it's not offensive
at all
[Music]
you ever smell your own sneeze
i have never and but i smell yours it's
very bizarre to me you could smell my
there's a smell and i've never seen that
before because i have like
enormous sneezes i think they're like
really explosive it's so weird
i do wonder if it happens to other
people i don't know if i had like super
smelling or just huge sneezes
i'll tell you exactly what it is because
i i have the same problem
dan can you hear me yeah go ahead um
it's something called tonsil stones
and what those are they're like plus
pockets of bacteria in the back of your
throat
and then so that causes the cup come up
and produce a smell
what never heard of that yeah i didn't
even know sneeze's head smells so
exactly i mean well hold on zach why you
got to accuse me of having pus
pockets in my mouth no no it's a common
thing
like i get them does yours do your
sneezes smell
occasionally yeah fascinating
yeah do you like the smell of your own
farts does everybody like the smell of
their own heart you try to omeprazole
that's what you take right yeah i take
i've been taking this [ __ ] every day
forever
dan do you like to smell your own farts
they're all right they're tolerable
gross why is
i just had the spot of smelling your
farts
well let me ask you ela do you smell
your own farts
well what what do you mean by that i'm
not saying you buttercup your face no i
don't do that but like if you're
in bed and you fart and it's a dank ass
nasty part you're not gonna like get up
no no never you know i knew a guy in
college and this was
the most bizarre thing i ever heard he
hated the smell of his own fart so much
he would get out if he was by himself he
would get up and go fart somewhere else
and come back
that's pretty wild i think i was like
what
i was so shocked by that but you
wouldn't say you like the smell are you
just too shy no i don't
like it it's i just don't it's not
really a problem i guess when it's your
own smell for some reason yeah
that's how i feel yeah like i don't like
it but it doesn't gross me out the way
somebody else's
yeah i don't like it right right you
guys ever caught someone cuffing
the smell like cuffing the smell and
bringing to their face
like people do that in public yeah they
like cuff the fart and then smell smell
their own bran
i used to do that i used to fart under
my covers and smell it
it's great man oh you're hot boxing
but it's been a while to be able don't
you mean the chat just said i love
the smell of my period blood i've heard
that i've heard that before
i hate it no i i that's a comment so
much
i've heard women saying that i think we
had a discussion on the podcast about it
we've talked about the smell but you
described it as comedy
right loving their own no specifically
women who
smell their own period blood or like
used menstrual pad
what do you mean you're into it what
does that mean you gotta get your wings
dude
stop it with the wings i know you're
joking but do you like the smell of
period blood no
yeah okay i just gotta get under there
anyway we're talking about this kid
who took a dump in a grocery store and
somebody
he jiggled it out of his leg and
somebody stepped in and i was like this
is incredible
and sure enough another one surfaced
where did this one come from discord
uh how'd you guys find this somebody
yeah i think maybe somebody posted in
the discord it's trying to get quite it
was discarded yes yeah
so credit to that discord and thank you
to all the members the discord is
popping you guys are the [ __ ]
you guys dude discord is awesome been
some really good content from there i
gotta say
fantastic so i was like dude this is the
same thing
except it's a grown woman really
in a mall for some reason takes a dump
in the floor and somebody immediately
steps
here she comes this lady in the moomoo
oh dude it's pretty incredible you could
just take a dump like that and nobody
noticed
oh there you go there she just laid one
on the floor bro oh my god oh my god
just
let it go i'll watch the guy slip in and
then homie slips in the dump
human feces bro
[Music]
does that mean she wasn't wearing
underwear how did she just squeeze that
out yeah
kind of right or did she
oh there it goes like yeah rolls down
her leg
too she must not be wearing any
underwear
yeah but the thing is if you know you
have a like leaky anus or whatever you
should be wearing a diaper or you just
don't wear underwear but straight
yeah exactly she went the other way
she's like nah i just
i dump wherever i go like a dog
kind of jealous of dogs so they can just
[ __ ] and pee anywhere they want
yeah including like a brand new couch
and
all of our carpets yeah stuff
yeah we got this big beautiful new couch
right now it's called
eno licking yeah you know alfredo never
really poops or shits or pees on
furniture
but we got this big beautiful new
leather couch
very expensive and alfredo took
a huge diarrhea on it like a big steamy
diarrhea
and it was there for a while too because
it was kind of semi-dried
anyway it stained that [ __ ]
there's it's just got a huge diarrhea
stain on it
but i was i'm not mad at him he's a
sweet boy i was just i was just found it
kind of
just a little funny like
he's never [ __ ] or pissed on furniture
then he takes that not only like it was
a normal [ __ ] also the couch was like
brand new like we i think we only had it
for a week and nobody's gone on it since
it's not like a common occurrence you
know
and it was if it was a normal [ __ ] i
feel like i could have picked it up and
recovered but it was a
steaming diarrhea yeah i could have
flipped it like a pancake
with a spatula you know
kela if i die early promise me
you better promise me right now elo
that you'll give me the send-off i
deserve
oh my god what no
are you serious yeah that's the that's
the send-off i deserve as your husband
so it's a woman there's an open it's an
open casket actually too
and she is twerking on the on the
casket and it's open too so and everyone
is down with this
hell yeah dude it's good last time i
mean why shouldn't a funeral be a good
ass time you know i don't know
kind of always thought about that maybe
not that much of a girl
she's like yeah i've been waiting for
you to go
um she looks kind of sad like is she
crying as she's doing this
well yeah that would make sense given
the context
but why did they saran wrap it too it's
kind of funny like they
i don't know it's covered in saran wrap
to protect it from from
being delivered so maybe it's part of
the delivery
protection
so they're like don't whatever you do
don't scuff up this coffin that we're
gonna
bury yeah that shit's expensive though i
understand
coffins are real expensive man it's a
hell of a thing to die
it's not [ __ ] up it's like i'm dead
and now i gotta cost a shitload of money
to get rid of my dumbass body
i don't think we do coffins in israel so
[Music]
it's like dude what if i don't like just
get rid of me just dump my ass
yeah it is really expensive you gotta
buy land
in the cemetery
and it's like can they will they even
cremate you in israel
because it's super taboo to not get
buried in judaism
i never looked it up
there's not that much land how do they
even make that much land to bury you
that's why it's so expensive
so what do you do if you can't afford it
i think they started doing like
multi-layer like uh
car car garage yeah like a building you
know
you're on floor one floor two that's
crazy
i wonder which is the best floor to be
on when the messiah comes back
closer to god oh
so okay i'm gonna give you guys a
straight up warning here
this is on the level you may guys
remember watch that video of the dude
puking at the ball game
now i love this i love that video
but i know some people said it's too
gross for me i can't do it
okay so i'm just gonna warn you right
now
i think it's hilarious video and i want
you guys to stay and watch it
but i just want to give you the fair
warning that this is disgusting
okay but it's awesome
so i really think you should try to
stick around and watch it
you know
by the way so yeah dude wherever this is
i'm not down
they're in like an empty lot there's
like trailer homes
and they're on some heavy machinery i'm
not i'm not down wherever this is
it's not safe don't go past the mess
your sides don't touch anything what is
this
what is this
which one do you think is going to puke
yeah why is it why is it so close to
just
regular neighborhood vibes dude they're
in an empty lot
what the [ __ ] this is not the place to
get on a carnival ride
hey you guys vote who do you think's
gonna puke the girl or the guy one for
the guy two for the girl
in the chat yeah in the chat so when you
first opened the video my vote was the
guy
okay yeah i also think the guy i mean
that that was my initial thought as well
he looks like super stressed
this is uh their second date apparently
too
how did you know that it was in the
title or what have you got someone said
second date at a theme park
is that confirmed or what i think that
was just the title of the reddit post
i'm not sure it seems like there's a
healthy mix of one yeah i see everyone's
saying
i see mostly one i see a lot i see a lot
of twos
yeah yeah i saw one three see to me i
thought the guy was people puke for sure
[ __ ] this ride by the way
like literally drive into the middle of
nowhere and get on a
janky ass rusty noisy ride
yeah and also why they have a shrek logo
where right here in orange
oh looks like the shrek logo
okay so here we go now now there's a
couple of things to notice first
let's do a play-by-play so
homie just as she keeps puking that's a
lot and a lot and a lot
and he just i if it happened to me i
think i would look away
to try not to answer something but he
he's like just
keeps watching silently like he's
getting off on it almost
that looks like she ate a lot at the
carnival that day
oh what's up oh and it's going right on
her
he goes are you okay
so here's my favorite part right now
like you're like wow how this
how could this day get worse yeah the
ride is just starting
this is when the ride gets really crazy
no this is awesome she's covered head to
toe
and puke and the ride starts going off
and guess what she ain't done
not even close and homie's just watching
don't watch [ __ ] i've always wondered
what happens when you puke when you're
upside down or something
he's like kill it
that's the worst job how do you go on
from here like oh
damn well how do you who's gotta go
clean that man yeah
that really sucks oh
boy do you make her clean it
you're a lady i have a feeling she just
walks off you think she's you don't
think she's going to go get popcorn or
hot dogs
or go on another ride do you think she's
ever going to talk to him again if this
is a date
she's smelling her puke bruh instead of
smelling her puke here let's go back
look at her
sniff sniff again
oh and he saw that he saw the sniff
she's examining the contents of her puke
there's puke on her [ __ ] something
oh good man
that's the best puke video i've ever
seen
in my humble opinion that is the
premiere puke video on youtube today
okay should we watch again no
really you don't want to i'm kind of
feeling it
oh man
so let's get a call going who else do we
have
do you want to try getting the harambe
girl back on zach
uh yeah she's in the collin queue i work
on
there's no guarantee that that let's try
again happen again let's try it again
go ahead
tell me when she's in
she's in right now okay can you hear me
hello hello hello hello
oh she can't hear can't hear anything oh
geez let me see let me try something so
jesus christ do you think it's on her
and dan uh well if zach talked to her i
guess
no i want to say it's so bad it's so
good
oh and i'm team h3 all the way
i don't know if you're talking to me or
if i'm talking to myself well we
appreciate it zach what do we do
can you talk to her and see i i really
want to talk to her
uh it sounded fine on my end yeah i
think it's on our end
i tested the discord we were
i don't know i even when i logged into
your computer everything seems fine i
don't know
you want to come tinker around a little
bit i gotta pee anyway
here eli you entertain the people i'm
gonna go really yeah
we gotta we gotta find out about harambe
all right let's see
all right um
questions let's see yeah i think we had
donations
take a look at that a little bit
detail about the funeral to work the
deceased was a criminal and the growth
working and the others are his criminal
friends
really
um what else we got here
friend of the show and i honestly
thought you would never show your faces
again
that's true that's true it'd be super
interesting to do everyone's
top five movies in the crew and
discussions
that would get pretty uh juicy i feel
like
very
that might be a good idea yeah i like it
um
i'm trying to read but uh having trouble
that's moving too fast yeah y'all are
donating too much study fresh can mean
i'm so excited thank you so much
um
um
when will you join the discord i
i want to i don't know why i'm afraid of
discord
i have like uh can someone explain why
am i afraid of discord
uh this course is scary well
i there's so many like stories of people
uh
you know getting cancelled because of
discord conversations or whatever and i
think it
i just have like a negative uh i'm
seeing this light application of discord
in my mind i don't even know why i think
we just had a glitch
i literally just closed discord and
reopened it and i can see
the audios coming through so here it was
alyssa right
yeah melissa hello are you there
alyssa can you hear us hello
hello can you hear us yes i can hear you
there we go hi okay alyssa
i understand your team h3 that's
fantastic to hear
um so as i understand it
you were there on the fateful day that
harambe left this deer
planet earth is that correct i was
such a crazy summer day i remember it
like it was 2016.
and so what was your job at the zoo what
city did this take place in
so it's in cincinnati ohio
i was a university student and i was
part of the fun department is what they
called it so basically
i helped ran run the train the carousel
i also worked the
parking lots the ticket booth scanning
people in
um and various other things like that
and so that day i was in the ticket
office and that's where we keep
all the radios and so it just like
suddenly went insane that day
with all the news and everything done so
when did you first learn about what
happened to harambe
well i was in the ticket booth office
where all the security
stuff is the radios and
you just heard people screaming and call
9-1-1 call 9-1-1
and it was actually one of my co-workers
who was walking by and saw the incident
happen
and so they rushed all the people into
like the reptile house and various
different areas secluded areas so they
could get the fire department and stuff
and the funniest part was we had the zoo
shut down everything was
totally turned off the fire department
was there everything
and people were still coming to the
window how much is for three people
two children i'm like i'm sorry we are
closed right now and they're like well
how much longer what's how long is it
gonna take
and i was like i don't know so they
literally waited
little bench outside my window for me to
open back up
did you explain did you explain what
happened to them like hey
uh a baby fell in the gorilla cage and
we killed the [ __ ] gorilla
no no we were trying to like keep it
calm
obviously and everything was so chaos so
we didn't have like
talking points in the first seconds you
know but the best part is like
they later i was working the um the
scanning where like
after once you come to the zoo you have
to scan in your past and stuff
excuse me a little bird sound like me
and
[Laughter]
um so i was scanning people in and this
little boy
was like what happened to the gorilla
and the mom like oh well we do offer
free wi-fi you can find the code over
there your mom can look
up and tell you all about it once you're
in the zoo right yeah oh my god
the little boy looked at his mom and he
was like
what happened to the gorilla mommy and
she said they shot him the [ __ ] hood
what the what is wrong with that lady
did anyone
barely walking i couldn't believe it i
was like oh my god and people were
trying to sneak in with like a little
pocket in their t-shirt you know and
they had like their
phone camera trying to record our like
responses and stuff
it was insane did anyone ask for a
refund
oh yes that was the next part we had
the whole because we were stuck in the
reptile house for 30 minutes
we had this traumatic experience happen
which i understand if you saw it okay
but
there's no way you could see or hear
anything if you're in a certain point
but
we did do the refunds and stuff but i
also used to work at
disney world in florida so this is like
nothing i've seen way too much
yeah yeah that's a lot of experience
between those two jobs
although i'm sure nothing could have
prepared you for that day what was the
what was the vibe like after harambe had
had
uh had been released from his mortal
shackles
was there was was the atmosphere there
with the employees did they miss harambe
did you feel oh yeah they had like they
offered free therapy sessions if
workers needed their outing and stuff
they did extremely serio like extreme
you know
um but then what happened what was i
going to say
well what what happened with when it
started getting memed on how did the
people at the zoo
handle that oh no so i was actually
getting trained like the next day
to work in membership um and that's
where we have a phone
and you can call and ask about our
membership and you have no idea how many
calls we got
people were slapping slapping slapping
their dicks on the phone leaving
voicemails sticks out for a run
[Music]
stalking our parking lot and i think
they like stayed in our parking lot
for like two weeks or something so we
charged them because it's ten dollars a
day to park
and it was it was crazy people were
always cussing and stuff but we
outside of the gorilla exhibit we have a
little statue gorilla and people
thought that we put that there for
harambe so there was like thousands of
flowers there
all of a sudden it wasn't there for him
no
it's been there for like the cincinnati
zoo i think is the second
zoo in the united states so it's like
super old
but wow what a tragedy
yeah and how and what are you up to
these days that was a while ago now
what are we up to now yeah so
i was traveling um earlier this year to
argentina for a few months because i
work online so i just go around
and um i got my flight was march 29th to
go back to florida because now i live in
orlando and
nope i've been stuck in argentina ever
since
and i'm 182 of strict quarantine
there's nothing to do they have they've
been opening up some parks
but it's just insane this is the city so
um still no trains no nothing uh
the grocery store is open but you can
only have one person at a time like
from each family member and things like
that well you're safer there
than in florida i'll tell you that
that's what i've heard that's what i've
heard well i did want to say
i worked at when i was at disney world i
worked with the stroller so we dealt
with a lot of ecvs
or the electric scooters as you know
yeah gatsby asks yes oh my god
they're the craziest people i love the
videos you show because
ah so there's truth to it to the meme
the people on the mobility scooters are
wild as hell
oh and disney mobility scooter let me
ask you this
do you suspect that what percent of the
people on mobility scooters really need
them
10 10 that's what i think
i really do i think no and it was
really bad because for new year's eve
because i worked i did that part at
epcot um
and for new year's eve epcot is huge and
stuff because that you can travel around
the world and drink when you've been see
your where but um you have to get
super early the first like 10 minutes of
us opening
all of our scooters are gone i don't
know how many we have like 100 or
something
they're all gone and it's really sad
because then the line is outside of even
the entrance to scan your pass
for more ecvs and wheelchairs and stuff
but we run out so we have to start a
list
and my boss was like okay alyssa i think
you can handle like
fighting people so i want you out there
telling them we don't have any
and there was so many people like
where's your list i want to speak to
your manager
my father doesn't have a legacy
well you're a true warrior of the h3
nation and we
we appreciate you for that you know
thank you so much
people in the chat love your voice have
you heard that before
i've heard a few people tell me that
interesting
is that something is that something
you've worked on or is it just your
natural
uh a tannin
no i think it's just my natural whatever
you the word you just said
well maybe i'll send you in to talk to
james charles would you be willing to do
that for me
absolutely let's change his mind i have
a better smile than him so let's do it
just kidding he's a really cool person
too but um
yeah thank you so much and i listen to
every single podcast as soon as they
come out because
all i'm surrounded by is spanish here
and i don't speak
thank you thank you thank you god bless
you god bless you thank you for all you
do in service of the world in the
super trooper nation
can i shout out to my little sister
who's a marine i don't get to see her
anymore but we watch the show together
shout out megan
rebecca
thank you god bless you stay safe all
right be good
you too bye thank you hey zach
that dude did her voice do anything for
you yeah kinda yeah
i didn't want to bring it up but yeah
when i was setting it up i'm like uh you
know
i wonder if you should just do phone sex
work like it doesn't matter
what she looks like at all it's like
she's got the voice
she'll make a kill um
does it have to go to sex is there any
other like thing that voice
well right now she's just trying to
you've got harambe
and karen's looking for scooters i mean
get on the phone and do some phone sex
they probably make good money
what about like a radio broadcaster
right
how do you get into broadcast you know
what you mean hi i've got hi i've got a
nice voice i'd like to do broadcast
not it probably goes a little phone sex
bro
and obviously i don't know what she
looks like but like oh oh
i guess uh tim dillon uh posted
something from whitney's house
she did like a uh sort of an open mic
thing at our house
yeah not really an open mic it's her
friends comedians who
they all tested and um it was outside in
her backyard
and i guess they saw me on his something
oh really story or his video but they
someone here asked how was his stand up
and he was so funny
he was like he was really funny probably
my favorite
i don't want to throw it
he's coming on our show and i'll give
you the date right now that was the
first time i went out of the house to do
something and it felt very weird we're
recording with him on october 15th
so it'll be out the following monday the
19th dude we have a great crazy lineup
coming up
yeah a lot of comedians yeah we have uh
well we're dropping an episode with
stevo next monday
which was great by the way i'm super
excited for you guys to watch that see
then next week we're recording with
andrew santino
and then the week after that tom and
christine are coming back
and the week after that whitney cummings
dylan is the weekend then i'm working on
bert for the week after that
so bert after that so we gotta we got
that so we have one final segment to go
over actually we have a lot left but
we have a lot left and we're at an hour
four things my family's coming over at
three for this [ __ ] dinner with
trisha
yeah but i don't want to i don't want to
wrap it up yet we've got more [ __ ] to do
here guys
you know or you tell me what you want to
watch you want to watch this douchey
tick talker
who goes in home depot and makes a huge
mess
or do you want to wat well
you want to watch this flash mob not
wearing a mask these guys are such
douches
hate these people all right hit it
do you know what i think so these people
went to target
[Music]
and as a form of protest took off their
masks and shopped without a mask
and um we you know we ask
so little of americans these days
to think of all the great sacrifices our
forebears have
have undergone for us you know yep um
you know we're during world war ii we
shipped our our
our brave men across the seas to die and
fight for this country
meanwhile the women toiled at home
rationed their
groceries so that we could i mean
everybody donated their pots and pans
people i mean yes and now
look how little we can we can ask of
people
simply wearing a [ __ ] mask while you
grocery shop
is too much these people are not willing
to sacrifice
even the smallest and then i mean
america it's our freedom say what
they all say it's our freedom yeah this
is america
right yeah that's true well
i mean you're in a private property and
they have a policy to wear mass so it's
not really true in this case
and that's very american but we are so
[ __ ] little literally so little and
they can't do it
they can't do it
[Music]
all right we're tired of shopping
we're tired we're shopping with masks on
oh
no this is the greatest injustice
you are the most selfish pathetic
people
[Music]
and what are you doing you're in target
like bro what kind of point are you
trying to prove at least go to a
government building or something you
know what i mean
this family is there okay she's shoving
her phone in people's face
such a disgusting behavior why are you
so proud of yourself
he thinks it's like uh aaron brockovich
or what's yeah when everyone's just
gonna take off the mask and join him
everyone's like dude it's all about
choice that's what she said it's all
right but you know these people are
anti-choice
or they're their pro-life right
so when it comes to abortion no choice
for a life when it comes to wearing a
mask
freedom baby it's all about choice
so mask the mask uh pick a lens off your
oxygen right that's what they think
i mean yeah you could say that you could
say it doesn't do anything
you could say it makes it worse i mean
you could say anything you want
look at the child abuse going on here as
kids like eight
i mean dude
cut cut to brave americans dying
stupidity
normandy this isn't freedom it's just
you're stupid
you're just dumb brave men dying on the
beaches of normandy
their wives back home rationing sugar
donating pots and pans
working in factories the
you can't even get all the gas you need
to do all the driving
the times are hard but we're willing to
pull together for the greater good
then flash forward 20 20.
[Music]
1942 the mother of three children gets
a let a knock at the door she knows
immediately
all three of her children died in combat
no sacrifice is greater for the country
or for humanity itself to fight the
evils
the necessary to save lives to save
democracy
cut forward 2020
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're not doing it anymore
shake it off cut back 1942
jews are lined up in a concentration
camp
the evils of the nazis who knows where
they're leading to but you can make a
good guess
right outside the gates the the allies
are marching across these horrid scenes
the liberation was worth it and all the
sacrifice has paid off
but at what great cost splash forward to
2020.
squash what's what is this
it's like a san diego zoo i'm trying to
give some kind of like shamu
concert a splash it's a cinematic splash
[Music]
these people are the ones most likely to
to say that oh
men these days are are so weak and in
soyboy cucks
yes but like these are the weakest
people on the [ __ ] planet no then
putting a mask on is for [ __ ]
no they're they're walking hypocrites
they're weak they're selfish they're
just i mean
yes everything i mean like i said you
can't stand a
piece of cloth on your face like this is
it's just
intolerable to you because they think it
makes you look weak or something i mean
it's just pathetic bro i just see it
yeah
it's total inverse of that it's like
can't be asked to do anything the
sacrifice
for freedom all we achieved
america the great country i mean you're
actually
just the manhattan project i don't even
know what to say it's so stupid
tanks airplanes convert pearl harbor
converting all of our great
manufacturing power
to overcome the forces of evil
children fatherless mothers sunless
flags are waving planes overhead
america is great and
what does a aien think about this
what do you think about these protesters
aien
smash cut to 2050
you have all wiped yourselves out by
sheer
moronic stupidity and the robots
rise so you're pro
you are pro covet truthers because you
think it will help
usher and the era of robots
uh yeah pretty much yeah that about sums
it up yeah so a lot of go off
everybody yeah i mean aien support your
guys's protest that should tell you
something
did you see his background oh no yeah
that's pretty good
yeah i wish they knew that ain't
supported them they
know and then again and then they make
this whole thing about like it's
patriotic to somehow do this it's all
american
of course
we are so we have become so pathetic
it's really american
to race other people's lives just
because you don't want to wear a mask
you know and i gotta say like we work at
the office
i go there about twice a week and
we all wear a mask and i think it really
works oh it's proven to work yeah i mean
no but i think it's that simple like
because in the beginning everyone was so
paranoid like
surfaces you gotta sanitize oh yeah
that's a big deal
when you open groceries you gotta do
like million steps
it's way simpler than that you just need
to wear the mask
it's really not that difficult like at
least do that
the cdc said if all americans just wore
masks the virus would be gone in four to
six weeks
gone i believe that because i see it
from our experience i just see it we had
a guy that
was positive you know nobody caught it
and nobody caught it and he was working
in the office at the time
i was close to him everyone was oh dan
was close to him
i moved a giant printer
um in a barber shop one of the
hairdressers
was positive but everybody who came in
that day and all the
hairdressers were wearing masks nobody
else got infected
mm-hmm [ __ ] it works just do it
anyway [ __ ] them speaking of people who
[ __ ] and by the way now that i'm on tick
tock i'm kind of a superstar
and i've been seeing we talked about
this channel without knowing it was them
um there was this we were talking about
the uh birth
or the gender gender reveal that started
the fires and i was watching that i was
like trying to explain what the oh yeah
why did you throw glitter on the gun
yeah so what about so i found their
channel browsing tick tock
and then i was like oh these guys are
just giant douche bags
oh they are the glitter is literally
just to make a mess
it's to make they're trying to confuse
this guy into thinking
they're pranking this guy they don't
know him oh and he's not even in on it
no
no oh so they go into stores they [ __ ]
with people
this guy doesn't know them that's not
it's a prank
bro and so this channel is one of the
most [ __ ] up things i've ever seen oh
my god
because not just because they're so rude
to people but because they make such an
enormous mess by the way it says five
million views
why would you do that for viewers
yeah for views but the thing is they
don't clean up not even funny though
500 views who are you to judge that's
just mean
dude they don't clean it up look at this
mess at least they wear a mouse
it's not funny by the way look how much
glitter they got in this guy's hair
views deal you don't know anything about
it it's not
funny he's got the guy cleaning him off
and [ __ ]
so here you see look how [ __ ] up this
guy's
hair is when he turns around
how do you even like where did that come
from that is such a shitty
thing to do so here's another one yeah
they just do this there's like a hundred
of these oh my god they just do it
non-stop
oh you wonder if they just get banned
from every store like eventually they'll
have nowhere to go
to do that oh the guy sees the camera oh
what a legend
what are you recording that for oh what
a legend
are you security
but then they get all defensive and they
make him look like a [ __ ] yeah
they're a weirdo bro those guys are
gonna do it to the wrong person and get
[ __ ] stabbed
i saw one today where this one guy uh
they wanted he wanted to fight and
they're like this guy's crazy i'm gonna
try to find it there's so many of them i
mean these guys are
these guys are just like serial
criminals or something
i gotta say they hear this one i kind of
i have to admit that i
[Applause]
i gotta admit that this one makes me
laugh i mean just blowing someone with
air
they both at the same time start
blasting out
i didn't know you could just use those
in the store
i mean if they were doing this kind of
stuff whatever you know wait ila watch
this one
[Music]
[Applause]
that's just the douche that one's not as
bad
but it's all bad yeah yeah given the
context of everything else they do [ __ ]
them but
if it was just that whatever this one's
got 10 million
[ __ ] crazy
oh god
what are you supposed to say you know
you got me
i'm trying to find this one of the dude
trying to fight him because it was
very good it was very justice boner
vibes
i wonder if they erased it because i
just saw it today surprised they would
post that yeah
well they always posted they think they
think it's funny even yeah they think
it's funny
exactly
was that like pop rocks
that's so cool got em
yeah this is the interesting thing about
tick tock is like all these pranks that
are
so uh
so old school and the [ __ ] that already
got chased off of
on youtube right yeah it's not popular
on tick tock
yeah yeah even have a don't judge me
challenge type thing
oh for real i've seen the i mean you had
that holocaust challenge i mean it
doesn't really get
any lower than that yeah man where's the
one the guy trying to fight him he was
like
he really was not having it
i love that one guy who just figured out
what happened
yeah that was pretty yeah that was
pretty happy
what
it's a prank bro i'm
it's
right
man oh look who it is it's the uh
convicted uh
pedophile snitched i didn't
look at the captain i'm supposed to be
loyal to you and you can't be
speaking
if snitching is right or wrong i really
don't give a [ __ ] about snitching he
told on a bunch of criminals
dude he [ __ ] a third like a 13 year
old on camera and filmed it
i mean his friend did yeah but he filmed
it yeah he probably [ __ ] her too i
mean probably but let's just but he was
slapping her ass and touching her boobs
and stuff he was feeling it yeah i mean
he filmed it so it's like let's really
focus like who
cares if you snitched on a bunch of
[ __ ] criminals i mean
was it really 13 yeah that's the eight
you're not exaggerating
i literally read that on wikipedia you
want me to read it to you oh my god
no he's he he's he's literally a pet of
like a
a sex criminal sick i don't even know
spell is dumbass name
six nine just replace the first
letter with the number that it's
spelling out
here you guys want to hear this kind of
i'll read it to you so when everyone
starts talking like this guy mike from
impulsive
he goes he made snitching cool
and i don't do and then they had him on
the show and all this
i was like dude why are you care about
snitching listen to this
2005 hernandez plead guilty to a felony
count of use of child and sexual
performance
he was charged with three counts of the
offense february 15
which he had physical contact with a 13
year old girl and later distributed
videos of the incident online as part of
his music video
three videos are described in the
criminal complaint against hernandez and
the first the child engages in oral
sexual intercourse
and is separately charged another
defendant
taqwan anderson while the defendant
danny hernandez stands behind the child
making a thrusting motion with his
pelvis
and smacking her on the butt the child
is nude in the video
the other videos show the child sitting
on hernandez's lap while anderson gropes
her breasts
and later sitting naked across the laps
of anderson and hernandez
he also was arrested for choking someone
at a shopping mall 2018. he was also
robbery assault and kidnapping in the
early morning of
july 2018 he was oh he was kidnapped lol
he was kidnapped beaten and robbed
interesting people are saying she told
them she was 18.
he's she's 13. bro that's not even close
i don't know people are defending that
what the [ __ ]
bro i think he knew very well how can
you mix
wait whoa whoa whoa straight up if you
want to defend him
call in right now i want to talk to you
and but
only if you really want to defend it
zach get one of these people on the
phone
how do you confuse a 13 year old with an
eight-year-old if she's 17
maybe 16 i can i can
stretch my imagination i mean 17 sure of
course yeah
you're right 13 year olds don't look 13
yeah sorry
yeah there's a big [ __ ] no [ __ ]
there's the big
but it's just crazy to me that people
are trying to defend him that's not like
16 18
or you know you know like turned in like
a kid
i have to say i actually think mike from
impulsive is such a [ __ ]
douche because like he goes on and on
about
this thing really solidified my feelings
for him i actually didn't really dislike
him for anything i know he he called me
out or whatever
but like he makes such this big deal
about snitching
but he brings the guy on a show who [ __ ]
who did this to a 13 year old girl i
mean
hello what
you know dan uh danny gonzalez had a
[ __ ] great tweet about it
he had a great tweet about it that i
want to show you guys
friend of the show danny gonzalez legend
i want to show you guys
legend look he says
hey if you see influencers that you
watch collabing with famous pedophiles
for views
just know they don't care about you they
just care about that sweet sweet cash
you know yeah that was really weird that
they had him on
well he's right it got like six million
views in a week i mean it's crazy
yeah but again it should i just find it
i mean
[ __ ] that he goes on and on about
snitching
i mean dude
try to act so hard in street you're such
a phony [ __ ] dude
kid [ __ ] like [ __ ] around with a 13
year old girl and filmed it bro
got your [ __ ] head out of your ass
douche
getting fired up
uh it's two o'clock do we need to uh
wrap this up soon we gotta i do think we
need to wrap it up
the other only other thing i wanted to
talk about which we can talk about
really fast
anyone excited to eat apples with honey
apples with honey apples with honey
hey hey i think you're going to be
surprised by how ghetto or rosh hashanah
is
i've done holidays with you already and
your family i know what i'm getting i
don't even know that we're dipping
apples and honey
all right i got that one covered oh you
did okay yeah
they do making the brisket say what zach
who's making the brisket you guys have a
brisket
i don't know i don't know actually i'm
doing the easy stuff like putting
apples and honey my sister's cooking
she's bringing everything else brisket
like a
tradition on rosh hashanah i don't think
so not in israel i come from
i don't think that's a tradition he's
just zach just wants brisket well i
think something like biscuit
so someone keeps asking where do i get
my chains
from um i it's just random i don't know
i'm not wearing this but it's not out
yet
not out yet um
yeah i don't really have a specific
place to give you unfortunately
thank you members we love you members i
see people member and get up
i want to um talk about one last story
logan paul is apparently boxing uh
floyd mayweather i don't think this is
gonna happen
i think this is an absolute [ __ ] not
ever gonna happen
i don't even think this is real
because last i heard um i think it's
real
no i don't because la the official story
that tmz put out and you know tmz is
always right about this [ __ ]
he says he was approached but he didn't
decide yet
and then you have people like keemstar
saying who kind of started this rumor
but i think he's wrong he's saying
um it's happening they already closed
the deal
yada yada yada he even leaked like this
whatever the [ __ ] this is what does it
say
let's see i think this was supposedly
just fight economics
who is this for you know what i mean
it's like a pitch deck garbage you think
you think they could sell 80 to 190
million that's crazy
for a pay-per-view well the thing is
floyd mayweather's super
i don't think ksi versus logan paul
pulled in not even close to that but i
think floyd
floyd could but why would he fight logan
paul like that's so
beneath him because a lot of money
but i don't think they'll make that
there's like no risk at all to him
like he's not gonna lose i mean it would
be pretty satisfying to just watch him
destroy him
seems dangerous i mean it does seem he's
not a trained fighter
i mean he sort of is now but but not on
that level
how is he he's zero and one
professionally i i
i get it but i just mean he's he's been
trained he fought one other amateur
right yeah he has no real experience in
the ring
he has no pizza experience either and
and floyd
mayweather is 50 and zero yeah no i'm
i'm i was saying he's gonna [ __ ] die
in the ring i agree
but yeah it's uh wouldn't that be kind
of crazy i mean would that be awesome if
he died let's not say that
i mean not i like you know awesome in
the in the sense of like
you would be in awe i mean it would be
required
here's the thing there's not a non-zero
chance that he dies
there's like a small chance he does die
yeah i mean boxing is very dangerous and
he's not
probably although i need to fight floyd
mayweather yeah i don't think floyd is
gonna go in there with the intention to
kill him
no of course not he's probably just
gonna toy with him put on a show
anyway i don't think it's gonna happen i
think it's all i would be shocked as
some [ __ ] of this happen
the shame is that of course i would
watch it
you know but why is logan paul getting
this fight ksi is the one that [ __ ]
won the damn fight
like why logan paul why is he getting
this huge payout
he didn't even win the damn fight he had
right i mean what the [ __ ]
first one was a draw second one ksi one
yeah
ksi is probably smart enough to not try
and fight
floyd matt whether it's the reason
well i think anyone right oh okay sorry
ela
sheesh i don't really give a [ __ ]
but thanks for letting me know
nice use of that i wonder if he's gonna
have to get tested for kovit the box
um no deal yet so we'll see
gosh that's crazy
people are saying he did have an
exhibition fight with some thai boxer
and he
destroyed him in the first round in like
10 seconds
so it's not unheard of you know when he
did the
well i guess the conor mcgregor thing
wasn't an exhibition that was like an
actual fight right even though
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean connor's a
that guy obviously yeah yeah he's not a
boxer though yeah yeah
although i recall was a pretty it was a
decent fight it wasn't even like
it was decent yeah but everybody knew he
was going to lose and he did so
anyway first few rounds it appeared
mcgregor had a shot but
mayweather pulled the easiest boxing
trick in the book and tire out your
opponent tired him out
that's what he did yep i think dan did
it best the other day if they actually
fight
he's going down to paul creed style
what does that mean i'm not familiar
with rocky trilogy oh apollo died in the
ring
right in the russian in oh he died yeah
in the second draw
the same one with the robot that we
watched the other day and that same that
same
oh they became a friend right they
became free yeah greatest movie ever
made
rocky fights ivan drago and he gets
killed in the ring
god do you guys think this will happen
uh i kind of do i mean yeah
i i i'm not as skeptical as you think as
i saw on tmz they said there's no deal
and i just feel like uh the thing is
he's such a
he's like a boxer through and through
right it's just such a spectacle i feel
like it cheapens the sport
so much but like you said you already
did it look at this one
what's that i want to call in i died
three times
and wanted to clear
do we really want to do this am i going
to argue with this guy about what the
definition of death i think you are
is there any way for me not to look like
an [ __ ] no
there isn't that's what i'm saying
there's literally no way for me to win
this argument
he does have he has more death
experience than you yeah so
uh 30 times because you're like i died
three times i'd be like well
it's just it's a semantical thing right
like exactly die
exactly that's not i'm just going to
look like a clinical
director the medical term
the key word is irreversible
irreversible death
a b don't encourage
if death doesn't mean death i worked i
worked
guys death is death if death isn't death
then
what word am i supposed to use when
someone actually [ __ ] dies that's
true what about when your heart stops
you stopping
your movie when your
yeah what's the problem your heart
stopped why are you getting so worked up
wait what happened i'm always been
arguing why you all
yeah ian what do you think about this
weigh-in please a-i-e-n
isn't alive he doesn't get an opinion on
this
listening to this conversation what say
again well if you're
just gonna talk over me i'm out so yeah
come on
you're so sensitive all right let's end
this show
yeah guess what what we're back next
week with a brand new mother lovin week
with stevo on monday
yes trisha on tuesday would
yes why do you say it like that what
were we going to maybe start doing those
on
wednesday release on wednesday no
okay but what uh so that the members can
get it early
oh i don't think so i think tuesday well
we'll talk about it
okay we'll figure it out treasure on
tuesday
and then another content court
right on thursday
and then we'll be back on friday to do
it all again yes sir a street podcast
you think he'll be back there well we
don't never know we never
are we in the midst of a h3 podcast
renaissance hilo well i don't think you
should acknowledge it because that kind
of
drinks it it's a great chance that's
what trisha was saying but i said
acknowledge it
well whatever we were [ __ ] doing the
show for so long it's a renaissance
fine i'll be michelangelo and you can be
uh the pope
so can you guys um can you say rosh
hashanah
rosh hashanah okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys want me to check my how's my
tick tock doing
feel free to end it any time well i'm
done
thank you guys thank you to all these
mother loving members and donators we
thought we all thank you so much
i want to thank uh the crew
thank you to everybody a b
dan of course
who's gone he's bounced with us we did
not respect his air time and we talked
over him
but it's kind of impressive that he's
capable of such emotions
yeah he tries to act above us like you
know he's sensitive
yeah he really is he's a sensitive soul
if he has his fault i don't know anyway
guys thank you to all the team who make
all this possible it's been a fantastic
week and look forward to doing again
next week so thank you guys
tgif tgif motherfreaker
[Music]
h to the three three three you're
watching h to the three three three
three
you're watching h to the three three